judith pogar is considered the strongest
ever female chess player and in this video
we're going to take a look at five of her most
excellent sounds like him in bill and ted's
adventure now moves and i have to say she was
a tactical genius and some of these moves are
simply stunning make sure you like this video and
subscribe to the chess.com channel and we're going
to move on to some beautiful beautiful moves
on the chessboard now we're starting off with
a nice easy tactic just to get you in the right
fame of mind in this one judah is playing against
pavlina chili guerrero off and it's judit to
play and win just look out for the back rank
if you struggle with any of the tactics i
show you do press and use that pause button
let's see if you can play like the great judit
queen takes f8 check oh yeah and here black resign
because after king takes the bishop is going to
slip into h6 and there comes the back ranker nice
and simple they will get harder i'm warning you
now i'm warning you now this game is considered
one of judah's most amazing and tremendous ever
games and it's clear why judith is playing against
vichywan anand one of the strongest players
of all time one of the things personally i
liked about and do like about judith's play
is her tremendous energy she kept on just
throwing pieces the kitchen sink there's there's
there's there's i know a rock there's a stone
there's a car she just kept throwing everything
at her opponents and i've kind of modeled some
my play on this to keep that pressure up it
must have been horrible for her opponents to
have this onslaught coming against them this is
shown here white to play and now judith comes in
with rug d6 another brilliantly energetic move
this attacks the queen and of course this queen
is tied down to the defense of g7 if it moves away
the queen comes in checkmate on g7 so anand plays
f6 but now bishop d2 and this lines up against the
black queen e4 another piece comes in b5 bishop e6
rook a7 and even though this next move may seem
a little bit odd it's one of my favorite moves in
the whole game because it just demonstrates that
judith understands that vishuan is totally tied
down here black is nearly even in a position of
zugswang whatever move black plays it can weaken
his position and this shows great understanding
and just the calm rookie six dominates black's
position black tried a5 but this is a nothing move
and now judith bit by bit improves her position
and with rook c7 you can see the pressure mounting
against black structure and judith went on to win
even though she's a piece down black just
can't move brilliant brilliant foresight
to make the sacrifice work and just look
at the energy of white's pieces there
we now move on to one of my favorite games of all
time often where you when you pair the elements
fire and fire against each other you're gonna
get an explosion and here you've got two of
the best attackers of all time judith playing
with the black pieces against alexei shiroff
and here judit dives in with queen takes g5 and
this is a way to stop not just win a pawn but
stop black from castling queenside the idea of
course is that the queen has taken the knight
will come in and win that queen the pawn on
e4 is actually pinned down because of the
rook and this is the start of just an amazing
couple of moves here where the black knights
really come to life shiro's problem is his king
is a little bit more weaker he tried to counter
attack with knight a5 hitting the bishop on b7 but
judith goes forwards and this next move must be
one of the most pleasurable moves she had
the chance to play i wish i could play a move
like this in my lifetime knight to e3 and this
just emphasizes her will and the way she played
forwards never retreating unless she had to and
playing with the utmost energy and aggression
and one of the things that's interesting here
is well maybe maybe white can take the queen now
thinking oh yeah thank you are you just giving
me your queen are you gonna resign judith well
maybe i'll play a check it could be mate just
look at that check mate oh oh it looks so good
and after knight e3 other options here are very
bad for example if white takes on e3 grabs the
bishop then the combination of queen and knight
combine beautifully with knight f free check
and queen d2 ending in mate and if queen to g3
has played in the game well now judith can just
win some material and she does and she goes on to
win a lovely game and you're not going to see many
nights combining to create a dance of death like
that in your lifetime here judah is paired against
fellow countryman fernandez burks and in
this position she sacrificed a piece on g5
and black has recaptured here what should
and did she now play the obvious move might
be capturing that rook but as you're probably
guessing the obvious move is not always the one
that should be played well the move she played
shows brilliant understanding of the position and
how to get through to the enemy's king she always
had our eyes on that king and she always found
ways through often in a very direct manner and
the brilliant move here is g4 now you might be
thinking hang on why is that brilliant well it's
brilliant because the idea is to simply play h4
but stop black from playing g4 therefore whatever
happens this h file will become open other moves
were not as strong this is directly going
for the king my kind of way of playing chess
and after rook b8 here she now goes h4
and you can see this file is opening
and let's just have a look how the attack
continued she now moves her queen into f4
and after bishop b7 yet another brilliant move
here it's blow after blow we're up to h7 check
and now the point of this is the queen comes
to h2 and if king g7 we have queen h6 and rook
to h1 and we can see it's going to be checkmate
coming up the king went back to g8 rook h1 anyway
and after bishop takes g5 judith just played f4
and here black had to give up his queen to stop
check mate so judith went on to win lovely lovely
energy yet again shown with that brilliant attack
well if you know you're attacking player you
have to play attacking openings and there's
not more of an attacking opening than the king's
indian defense and in this position judith has
black against alexander chernin and here we can
see that judith has a lot of pieces quite nastily
placed against that king and after the move bishop
d3 she now broke through how did she break through
she played rook takes g2 check again
forcing away through to the king
if king takes queen h3 as checkmate and
after rook takes g2 just bishop takes h3
and this is building up to a major discovered
check and with the other black rook coming in
white's king is in the middle of an onslaught the
game continued knight to e4 and now another piece
comes in typical judah every piece jumping into
action knight takes e5 bishop takes e5 the bishop
now lined up and after knight g5 well we can see
that white is simply lost as judith takes on g5
she's actually a pawn up here but with rook
g8 black resigned after only one more move
and that is f3 with some nasty checks coming next
deadly attacking play from jude fantastic stuff
so which of those five moves was your favorites
they were some stunning examples of energy and
using the initiative at the chessboard we can all
learn from judith's play and she was the strongest
ever female player and a brilliant all-round chess
player being one of the best in the world let's
just remember not just a strong female player
but one of the best chess players combined with
any sex or whatever that's irrelevant
and we can see that from a brilliant
wins make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel and leave your comments below